the Joe Rogan experience you want to
talk about Co vid I do what are your
what are your thoughts on that what do
you thoughts on the lockdown yeah well
let's put it this way I'm not speaking
in a vacuum here I've heard a certain
amount of your take and my take is a bit
different I am very concerned about SARS
Cove - I am NOT concerned about it
because it is as lethal as we feared it
might be
it isn't as lethal as we feared it might
be but I'm afraid of it for other
reasons one it is brand-new to us
evolutionarily it just showed up in
human beings and so in my opinion we
screwed up the lockdown badly because we
went half way that a very short very
intense lockdown could have ended it and
that that would have been the smart
thing to do and unfortunately the
political will was not there but if
you're I am looking at New Zealand with
utter envy imagine at this moment being
free of SARS Cove - yeah they nailed it
but they also have so few people no they
definitely had it easier but the point
is they did prove it was possible yes so
in my opinion we should have locked down
severely for six weeks or something
along those lines and we should have
driven it to extinction and the problem
is that that runs afoul of all kinds of
things including civil liberties
concerns which I also hold I hate the
idea of a government crackdown in which
they're dictating with whom you
associate and all of the rest I mean I
hate it as much as anyone but we are
dealing with a brand-new landscape when
it comes to a global pandemic and what's
more we are dealing with a virus that I
think is not what we have been told it
is how so so I have initially I thought
that this was a bat borne virus that had
been transmitted to people from the wild
probably through the bushmeat trade
probably through the seafood market in
Wuhan
in fact Heather and I were in the Amazon
where we had no connectivity to anything
for a couple weeks and when we came out
what was then called novel coronavirus
was just beginning to be discussed and
it so we became aware of it as we came
out of the Amazon's like oh what the
heck is not huh and I looked into it and
immediately I saw the story adds up you
know it's a corona virus of a kind
that's known to circulate in bats
there's a seafood market and I thought
okay I know what the story isn't I
tweeted I don't know enough about the
story yet but looks to me like the Wu
hen on seafood market is the source that
the virus comes from bats and we have to
talk about the bushmeat trade which has
always been a terrible idea and
immediately people tweeted back at me so
you think it's just a coincidence that
there's a biosafety lab level four in
Wuhan where this started and I thought
what that's a heck of a coincidence and
so I started to look into it I retracted
the tweet I said maybe I don't know
enough about the story yet and I started
to look into it and I went down the
rabbit hole because as much as we have
been assured by a huge range of experts
that this has to have been a bat borne
corona virus transmitted to people
possibly through pangolins maybe through
some intermediate host that we don't yet
know that story looks less and less
likely and the story that is looking
more and more likely what I would call
the lab leak hypothesis is looking ever
stronger and anyway I've been in contact
with other people who have reached that
conclusion we have faced all kinds of
pushback but in a sense again we still
don't know it is possible that this came
from the wild without human meddling but
the the virus itself has several
components that suggest that it is
actually the result of manipulation in
the lab and that it escaped
probably from the Wuhan Institute of
biology but there's another lab in Wuhan
it it may well have escaped
and we may be dealing with consequences
are the of the the fact that it was
manipulated in a lab so one of the
techniques that labs who study viruses
like this they use is something so the
research is called gain-of-function
research gain-of-function research means
you are taking a virus and you are
adding a capacity to it in order to
study how it works and then one of the
things that is done to study how it
works is something called passages where
a virus is infected and a creature is
infected with the virus and then the
virus is allowed to pass between
individuals of that species it can also
be done in tissues and cellular tissues
where the tissues are infected and the
virus is allowed to spread from one cell
to the next and what happens is
evolution so there is a strong
possibility that this virus was under
study that it was enhanced in the
laboratory and that we are dealing with
consequences that are the result of that
enhancement that make it more dangerous
than it would otherwise be and what do
you believe those enhancements are well
so the enhancements of one of the
enhancements there is a something called
a foreign site a fern site in the genome
of this virus fern sites are not known
it doesn't mean they don't exist but
they're not known from other beta corona
viruses and this fern site is
conspicuous its conspicuous in that it
is in the genome is an insert rather
than mutations of nucleotides that were
there it's like somebody spliced it in
that's one thing which could happen
naturally but it may well not have and
it has a flanking sequence which has
this is probably gonna be hard for
people to follow but nucleotides that is
DNA code for proteins which are made out
of amino acids there's an amino acid
called arginine and there are two
arginines coded for in the genome of
this virus but because there are so many
possible codes triplet codes
and only 20 or so amino acids there's
redundancy and so which code is used to
trigger the production of an or the the
inclusion of an arginine is variable and
the two arginines are coded for in a way
that is not seen in in nature in this
way very frequently so let's just say
there are elements of the genome that
are conspicuous and suggest possible
laboratory manipulation the fern site
that I refer to that has been inserted
either by a natural process or a by a
laboratory process greatly increases the
transmissibility of this virus which
means various things it could be the
explanation for why this virus is
infecting so many different tissues in
people who get sick right the list of
symptoms is huge here and that's a very
troubling thing from the point of view
of treating it medically is all of the
things that can go wrong with the body
once you're infected it also means that
the virus is very good at jumping
between people and that high
transmissibility is obviously one of the
things that makes kovat 19 such a
difficult pandemic to control right it's
hopping between people so readily that
it just it runs away so in any case and
then there's a third question that I
have which is maybe that there's
something about the fact I don't want to
say fact as if it is a fact but if this
was an escape from the laboratory then
the virus I mean just as you know maybe
we'll end up talking about the telomere
problem in mice which you spoke to Eric
about then he was on your podcast last
but evolution to the lab evolution in
the lab takes place and changes that the
people in charge want to happen occur
and then things they're not even
thinking about occur there's adaptation
to the laboratory at the environment the
people who work in labs are on unaware
of and so one of the questions I have is
this virus is highly transmissible
unless you're outdoors
then it seems almost not transmissible
that's a very conspicuous I mean for one
thing bats live outdoors right so is it
possible that this virus has adapted to
the laboratory environment an indoor
environment and that it has forgotten
how to get transmitted outdoors and if
we are casual about the outdoor
environment that actually it could
relearn that trick that we should take
it we a we need to be outdoors for
various reasons one it appears that
vitamin D is very protective in the case
of kovat 19 prevents the transmission
and you end up way less sick if you have
proper vitamin D so in the northern
hemisphere here while the sun is shining
we should be outdoors we should not be
locking down those environments at all
we should also be very careful outdoors
right because anytime we allow it to be
transmitted outdoors that is going to
that creates a evolutionary signal a
selective signal that's going to retrain
the virus to be transmitted outdoors
which is not something we want at the
moment this might be an advantage that
we have and we're gonna lose it if we're
not careful look is why I'm very careful
and why I wear this thing around so that
you know I can pull it up at a moment's
notice if I'm going to talk to somebody
because even though I think the virus is
very difficult to transmit outdoors
which is something we've seen in the
data of South Korea for example it could
learn that trick and why is it easier
for it to Trent do we know why don't
know indoors we don't know so we don't
know the mechanism and there's no good
reason that we don't know we should know
because it could be that it's UV light
UV light is very powerful destructive
stuff but if it's UV light then that
suggests it's difficult to transmit
outdoors during the day and it should be
easy to transmit outdoors at night if
it's not UV light then that's not likely
to be it so there is something weird
going on with viral load maybe it's not
weird but it's it's weird for those of
us who learned how viruses work from the
usual textbook diagrams where a virus
gets into a cell and triggers and
infection but here it seems like if you
talk to someone briefly your chances of
pick
it up from them even if they're sick is
pretty low but if you talk to somebody
for an extended period of time where
you're constantly breathing air that
they're exhaling then your chances go up
up up and up and that's so there's a
possibility that just exposure to UV
light as people even if they're outside
talking for the same amount of time just
the fact that these particles are going
through the air in the sunlight that it
kills the virus's ability to transmit
it's possible I don't know that what I
would say is first of all I do think I
am very much in favor still of driving
this thing to extinction by being
properly sober about it briefly tonight
pause in addresses one issue that seems
to be sure when it seems to be an issue
when someone says that it might have
come out of a lab this is a right wing
left wing thing for whatever reason you
get labeled a right wing conspiracy
theorist if you think it came out of a
lab and you people on the left are so
they're so willing to dismiss that
without any real evidence for we've been
poisoned by these these ideologies when
it comes to conspiracy or whether or not
something is actually true but we've
been fed the wrong information that that
stuff is if you don't believe the
official narrative that's being
discussed on CNN you must be some sort
of a right-wing nut right and have you
faced that oh of course I faced it I've
been I'm it's hard to escape it right so
I've tried to be very careful I have
described it as a hypothesis which is
what it is I have tried to show that
there are different probabilities for
the different origin hypothesis even
China now it admits that it wasn't from
the seafood market do that oh yeah what
do they say it's from well don't they
say it's from us I have not heard that I
have but they let's put it this way
there are one of the things that is in
my opinion the strongest piece of
evidence that there that the lab leak
hypothesis may be correct is that there
is a missing phase in the evolution of
this virus
when a virus jumps from one species to
another it is not well positioned it is
typically very poor at its job because
it doesn't have any evolutionary
experience with that host so it's not
good at leaping between that host cells
which means that it's always in very
small numbers and it's not good at
leaping from one individual to the next
that's the key question when something
leaps into a new species and then it
becomes a pandemic it's because it has
solved that second problem it has
figured out how to infect that creature
in such a way that the creature spreads
it to others of its kind there is no
evidence in the case of this virus that
that happened it showed up in Wuhan and
spread immediately it became pandemic it
already had experience now how it got
that experience we don't know there are
evolutionary ways this could have
happened right it could be that we have
not found the initial population that
it's circulated in right or it could be
that it circulated in a creature that we
haven't found either but the fact that
there is no evidence that it shows up in
Wuhan and immediately spreads tells us
that this virus was well adapted to our
cells and well adapted to transmit
between individuals and that is
conspicuous one way you could get there
is if somebody a had added components to
a virus in order to make it
transmissible to humans so the research
in question would be research that was
interested in discovering what a
pandemic in humans of a bat borne
coronavirus would be like so that we
could do something about it
maybe we could prevent it maybe we could
create a vaccine ahead of time but if
you're creating a virus that has
enhanced capacity to infect humans in
order to study what will happen if a
virus ever escapes into the human
population then you are running the risk
that the virus you are studying will
escape would they have added something
like a fern site absolutely it is
established in the literature that the
addition of a fern site makes the virus
much
more transmissible in human tissue so if
you were going to study it this would be
high in your list of things to do you
could also passage it through human
tissue in order to effectively train it
on the infectious pathway inside of
people which again we might be suffering
the downstream consequences of that if
it escaped the Wuhan Institute of
biology so these things have an amazing
impact and I hear a lot that what does
it matter it's with us now we just have
to deal with it which is nonsense
because a we need to have it never
happen again be there may be things that
we could understand about what its
nature is that would help us fight it
but see we have a really serious problem
now because all but a few of the world's
leading virologists the experts in
coronaviruses in particular have sworn
that this must have come from nature and
couldn't have come from the lab which is
nonsense why do you think they did that
unfortunately this goes back to our
earlier discussion our scientific system
is broken
we need our scientists to be empowered
to tell us what we need to know and we
need them therefore to be freed from a
system where they are fighting for grant
money in order to continue their work
this entire group of people is now in
jeopardy because if this turns out to
have been a leak from the lab then we
are all suddenly going to become aware
that gain-of-function research puts
humanity in jeopardy that one accident
in gain-of-function research can cause
the evaporation of who knows how many
trillion dollars it could cause and this
is one of the other things i wanted to
say to you about the danger of letting
this virus run its course
if we don't stamp it out we a don't know
that people who have been infected are
not going to continue to have outbreaks
we don't know that yet we don't know
whether or not people who've had it are
going to be immune to it in the future
that's probable but it's not certain and
we don't know that it's not going to
become a permanent fellow trial
of humanity the way flu is and even if
this thing evolved to become flu-like if
it became as unserious as the flu the
flu is very serious and the cost that
humanity pays for having flu circulate
every year is immense so even if the
only thing that has happened in the long
term if we let it go and it evolved into
another flu like pathogen then we have
increased the number of flu like
pathogens that we have to deal with
annually substantially and that would be
a major loss to humans so my sense that
we should be much more aggressive about
dealing with this is really about the
fact that I think we have a short time
horizon in which to deal with it that it
will learn new tricks and it will become
harder to defeat the longer that we play
around with it and so an aggressive
short to remove it's really you know
it's the lesson of pulling off the
band-aid we're not doing ourselves any
favors by pulling it off slowly
so what do you think we should do right
now well I would say I mean the problem
is it's a much harder argument to make
now than it was at the beginning because
we're all so frickin sick of lockdown
I mean Portland is still under full
lockdown but not when it comes to
protests well of course not that's the
other problem right there's a massive
hypocrisy in the way we're treating
businesses versus treating protests oh
it's an epidemic of hypocrisy not only
that de Blasio in New York City won't
allow people when they're asking people
that have tested positive for kovat 19
you're not allowed to ask them whether
or not they've been in a protest so
they're doing contact tracing without
valuable data because they they want to
be progressive that's insane
well he's insane yes so you asked me
what I would do I would and again I
don't want to be in this position you
know months in here I want to be in this
position months ago of saying the right
thing to do is a 6-week lockdown that
will be unbearably painful but hopefully
we'll be short and then intense contact
tracing but we've done a lockdown with
essential businesses open well we've
done that's not a real lock they've done
a half-assed lockdown and the thing that
we've done that I find the most
troubling is that we have not
bootstrapped
a mechanism for high quality ubiquitous
testing because if you want to do if you
did a six-week lockdown a real lockdown
right hold your breath and get through
it and then you open back up with
testing that's so high quality and so
Universal that you can spot anything
that happens and you can treat it
locally right you don't come into work
if you don't pass this test and if your
work puts you in contact with other
people were going to test you regularly
right if you did that we could have
driven it to very low levels and then we
could have dealt with the flare-ups but
what we're doing now is we're just
gambling and it's insane right we're
gambling and there is no that I can
detect there is no movement that says
open back up and be very aggressive
about things like masks my feeling is if
you're pushing open back up you ought to
be pushing things that would make
opening back up as safe as possible
[Applause]